Very good afternoon to everyone who
is listening to me today My name
is Óscar Antonio Bermeo Blanco I am a
veterinarian and zootechnist from the
University of Caldas in Manizales
Colombia since 1993 and I lived in the
United States 17 years ago and I have been
working  with research animals
approximately 14 years
and in research surgery
approximately 8
years So I
work for a company that is
dedicated to research to
preclinical research the company is called
Beteo here in the state of Ohio in the
United States uh in the center of the
oo state and
Ah from here we uh everything we
do in the company is preclinical research
Eh My job is as a veterinarian
uh it's
Ah basically all the clinical care
of laboratory animals
and my other job is as a
research surgeon which doctor
A  implement different eh eh equipment that
is needed to Ah we are from We are the
types of research that we
carry out
and at this moment
and
this presentation
eh
obviously I have done it in others in
other eh conferences and I chose this one
because it is a it is a very very team
Importantly, it can be used
for different
research. I am also a member
of the academy of
research surgery, which is worldwide,
but I reside here in the United States
and I specialize in
research surgery. About 4 years ago, I
specialized in C
research. So  Today we are going
to talk about the implantation
of catheters and vascular access ports
for the infusion or collection of
blood in different
species I think you see there the
first the first slide that
tells me white but the truth is
that Antonio but when  This country arrives,
everything like the name, so I
was left with Anton,
Tony. Well, then, that is the
title of our presentation today
and it is a very important topic. I am going to
first give a general knowledge of what they
are. I
call them the VIPs.  or
and basically the Here I put the
first initial vascular access ports
So the vascular access ports
are designed with a catheter that is
implanted in a blood vessel is
connected to a titanium port and the
titanium port in the entire middle has
uh a  silicone block and you can
obviously everything that you see is
implanted under the skin and it is
basically sutured to the subcutaneous tissue
so it is like an overview of
what a vascular access port is
an
introduction to the No I call them
baps or vascular access in
Spanish as chronic use the catheter is
implanted in a blood vessel and the
vascular port is generally made
of titanium or plastic and is implanted
subcutaneously was developed as
an alternative for external
blood access and are designed to
reduce problems  of thrombosis and
infections well any history
related to the development of
vascular access ports Ah they
were originally developed for
chronic use in humans with
drug infusions for cancer patients and
patients with eh chemotherapy
Ah it has been used in
laboratory animals since the  Approximately the 80s,
possibly before, but that
is when the most frequent use
began in that decade and
today it has gained quite a bit of popularity.
It is another Another aspect in Another aspect
in this slide of how What are the
BS the port, let's say the titanium port
and the needles that generally the needles
used to access these rooms
are called
her. Let's talk about, in general,
how they are implanted and how they are used
for those who
like it a little bit.  about literature
and for those who like eh
Generally
and How do I know where they have been named and
some of the history of these
vascular rooms and their use in laboratory animal medicine
Here I have some
references so you can search for them on the
internet and eh  in some cases they can be
done Translate but it is important
to read a lot about the
vascular access devices before using them
and before implementing them and before
using them obviously here Some
references articles are in English
but can be translated into Spanish
Obviously with with
aids  from the
internet
Ah here more references about
its true uses
and its different applications in
laboratory medicine and in
clinical PR research so in summary
eh one of the
most common surgical procedures in experimental surgery is
intravascular catalyzation for the
injection of
experimental products obviously  or
blood collection uh the catheters and the
Vips or the baps have been designed to
reduce problems of thrombotic occlusion
and
infections Compared with a percutaneous catheter
obviously well it's a lot of difference
because all the all the B It's
below the skin and  es and the catheter is
basically implanted inside
the blood vessel. So the difference is very
important
for its use and the implantation of
this type of devices. It is essential
to use a completely
sterile technique and use solutions that
prevent blood clotting and the
retention of waste in  the
internal part of the catheter and the B
obviously Ah advantages of
vascular access ports so one of the
advantages of the tilt access ports
is that you always have
immediate tilt access. So you don't have to
characterize anything about those things
but rather  everything is immediately
true so it reduces the need to
use multiple
intravascular injections. In other words, you don't have to
try to do a venipuncture
because 15 but always
immediate access without the need for multiple
injections.
In some cases, the
use of devices that restricts is reduced.  the
free movement of laboratory tiles
then Many times when one has
to do punctures then one has
to restrict movement of the animals
and use some devices to
be able to say restrict
their movement with the BS it restricts much
less this this type of situations
then  In some cases, you can
say, put the animals in a
jacket with a
pocket where you can place a
pump and connect it to the catheter and the B
that way the animals do not have any
type of restrictions
and advantage over percutaneous catheters, which I have
said a little bit ago, there is a
risk of infection, there is a risk of the
catheter coming out of the blood vessel,
all the components are implanted
internally in the case of
vatos implantation
What is the implantation like How is the
process then for implantations in
the jugular vein Generally the
surgical procedure is performed
under
general anesthesia Generally I
use isoflor Ah with
general anesthesia basically It is approximately 1
l per minute of oxygen and between
two 3% of isane in the vaporizer and it is
a procedure that takes approximately
half an hour 45 minutes depending
on the size  of the animal and depending on
the species in which
this
vascular access is being implanted for the implantation of the catheter
and the bar we implant in the saphenous oatmeal
of the leg in monkeys. Another alternative to
general anesthesia is the use of anesthesia
with
injectables. For example,  the
tilas eh ketamine and cacina and and other
injectables one can do a
heavy injectable anesthesia And then be
able to in that way be
able to
say make it less invasive And place
the catheters through the saphenous vein and and the va
Generally in the lateral part of the
thigh or in the inner part  of the thigh
depends on the species Generally in
monkeys it is on the lateral part of the
thigh, two surgical areas are always prepared
the area where the blood vessel is
where you are going to look for the
blood vessel the area where
the access hole is going to be implanted
tilt
Then first an insertion is made
into the
skin, a dissection of the blood vessel is
very important that it be a dissection, a
clean distraction means Well,
you have to clean the vessel very well
and the implant to ensure that it is made of
non-absorbent structure material, that
is, the implant  You must
ensure the implantation of the blood vessel
of the blood vessel you have to
use material that is not
absorbent Generally, it
is either materials that are not absorbent
because it is important here that
the catheter is well fixed to
the vessel.  It has not to move from the
vessel. One of the very important things
for this surgery
is to use a troca to pass the
catheter from the area where it is going to be implanted,
then save some photographs
in
which it is more of a better instruction
on how to use  the trocker of the part
where you are going to do the catheterization with
the trocker and the part where you are going to put
the
B, connect the catheter with the b and
secure it to the subcutaneous tissue with
non-absorbent material then
also once connected it goes to the
part
let's say where the  The catheter joins with
the B so that part of
structuring and the Val structuring the
material to the subcutaneous tissue also
means that it is well fixed in the
tissue circ below the
skin before closing the skin with
absorbent stucture material must be
blocked  The catheter goes with a solution.
It is very important. Once the
cer is implanted and the B is
implanted, then you must put
anticoagulant solution so that obviously
if any type of blood flow goes
to the catheter, it does not go inside the
catheter.  It is an
example so here we are showing
How this is the part where it has been
inserted
I show you
so this this let's say it is
the one with the
catheter as I am showing here and here
under the skin right
a package is being made in which it goes  to
implant
the So what you are telling you
This is the
truer is a trer This truer So you
go from one side to one side where you are
going to catheterize
uh the blood vessel to the other
side of this side to the other side
where you are going to  take out
to make the implant
is a clearer photograph
so here we have
the the
blood vessel the catheter has already
come out with the trer here Here it is at
the tip the tip of the catheter that is going
to be passed through the blood vessel it is
important  You must have two sutures
like Come here This is a
suture here so that
the blood flow does not go away from the vein or
the vessel. They can also be arteries. No,
but in veins, in some cases
we use it in arteries.  also and And
then there is this this
structural material that is here is used to
restrict the flow while one
installs the catheter inside
the vessel well another thing is important
and is
that some of these catheters that are made
of polyethane or silicone some  of
those catheters they have
eh I don't know if you can see well
here but they are called some
retaining rings some retaining rings that
are here You can see in the
diagram you can see there those those
help to
establish How much how much of the Cat  it is going to be
put in the vessel then depending
on the animal depending on the weight of the
animal depending on the species
which is being implanted so
this this catheter one the depth
again inside the vessel towards the
internal part of the animal is it is also
important so
what  I was telling him that I'm going to
put
some
retention measures to hold the vessel while
while you're implanting the
catheter or whatever else can be done,
these are like some
kind of thing, they're like some kind
of thing, some strips of ca, these strips
of rubber will do it.  What they do is
keep
both parts of the vessel occluded
while one introduces
here intru there once it is already
introduced simply relax
relax these relax
these rubber bands And then
the
catheter is introduced Well here we are showing it
is with non-absorbent material
so  I was showing Generally
I use to put
this well the B put it well
basically the muscle tissue so what you
use is some deura material that is like
nyon dent within your
capabilities
well some considerations before the
procedure so before the
procedure I always start with
analgesics  They must begin before
surgery, here we
use, for example, some
very
common narcotics, such as morphine, 30 times
more powerful than
morphine, and I also use non-steroidal anti-inflammatories,
such as caric, that are common.
Here, I use very common
and as we are working on
channels.  that they are in an environment in a
microenvironment in a cage in a place
where it is their environment so
Generally I
use racin as preventive antibiotic therapy for at least
7 days
At least for a few TR days and generally
only on the day of surgery because well it
is not either  a very
invasive surgery one of the things that are very
important for this type of
procedures is that it is recommended that
the technicians observe the animals
in detail so that they are
familiar with the
normal daily behavior of the animals what
I mean is that the technicians must
be very
familiar with the animals.
So if something changes after the
surgery, they will identify that it is
something not normal and then
call the Veterinarian and discuss what
is
happening. It is recommended to increase the
use of non-conventional foods.
What I mean is that every day
Generally they are given
certified concentrated food. Generally we
like to
give them before and after
giving them some foods, for example, that
are not conventional, for example,
fruits,
vegetables, other elements that are not
conventional so that they  not always
surgery recovery from surgery
always produces back narcotics produces
some loss of apti
so that faster after
surgery ento get with unconventional foods
then there are some
soft canned foods that
can be given to them soak
juices concentrated food  in juice
like Tank or coade or something like that that the
animals like it that the animals
like it or water well it is something that eh
For example in dogs we use
canned food that for example is
called that they like it a lot and  Also
for the monkeys we give fruits and vegetables
after
surgery and in the appointments we give them
quite a lot of vegetables and fruits they
like there in
apples Well one of the
critical parts after having
implanted these
vascular accesses is the proper maintenance
of  The BS is critical so eh the
frequency And who does it and all that is
very important and the training of the
technicians who eh are going to carry out the type
of maintenance while the
animals go to study or before
the animals go to study then  eh
to access the B It is necessary to carry out
a completely sterile preparation of the
field where you are going to access eh
for the preparation it is recommended to use
products that contain chlorexidine or
isodine then They
are generally for surgical use and and it
is like a chlorexidine soap
like an
ISO soap that is used to make the
preparation
sterile other surgical field preparations
used Like for example
the is from a company called 3M
that has residual antimicrobial activity
is a is a isodine polyacrylic
basically very very very effective
approximately after  It
lasts 72 hours or less with
residual antimicrobial activity in the
skin. It is very
important to use needles.
Special needles do not use other needles but
those indicated for the
vascular access port to which it was
manufactured, then according to the
manufacturer's recommendations in
relation to  What type to use for
that particular type of vascular access
Generally the lasas that we use for
normal access are
needles and others for another type of
needles are like these that I am going to show
here is one that is
true and another is called pencil tip
for another  type of bas that is called by
Hol the ones that are like
this one so the difference is that this one
is like a needle like you read the tip
similar well but more or less the idea and
these have a tip like a pencil and the
little hole which
is  It is made on one side It is
made on one side of The basically
of the needle but the tip is
more or less like a pencil tip
Well then this is for another type of
this needle is for another type of
vascular access Port vascular access
that  They are
called and then we talk a little more
about
them solutions used for what
we talked about before to block the
port access
vascular access we use
50% deosa perine in sodium catho 4% And well
obviously
conine saline solution I mean  There are different
combinations, many combinations
depending on the type of study,
depending on the preference of the
researchers. Well, it depends on many
things, but in general. There are many
combinations. For example, I
generally use Destro at 50% to a
solution combined with heparin at 200
units per centimeter.  It's more or less
what I use
and in some eh eh For example in
laboratories when they have catheters
then
we use other types of
solutions that they already sell basically
ready to use and they are Generally
contain more or less 500 deine units
per
cubic cm well There is  many
combinations what we are talking about
sterile preparation to be able to
Access the to the B very
important the preparation of the patient
ent the most important thing is
to locate the location of the bp
that if it is well shaved That is, you have
to cut the hair very well at the level of
the skin  practically eh prepare the
place with eh oina etc. that we had
talked about, do not allow the air to become
contaminated, that is, try to ensure that if there are
too many
eh
things around, try to prevent them from
suddenly falling down, where the
area that is going to be prepared is very  It is
important that the area is as safe as possible to
prepare to avoid
contamination. So the most important thing
is to try to establish an aseptic area
where you can have easy access to
all the materials for
maintenance.
the needles
all those types
of issues that you need to be able to
do maintenance try to
establish
an area with no one other than the
person who does the preparation and the
person who does the access to the B use
that area that I do  The thing is that
I generally use gloves that are
sterile and they come like on a piece of
paper, so what I open is the
paper, I put on the gloves, and that paper
where the gloves are, I
generally put all the
materials that I'm going to use to
make.  access to the
vascular port How to use procedure
utilization Well then we were talking about
making sure that the needle is in the
in the B with a jinga try to collect
the previous blockage then then
you suction whatever is in the B whatever
is in the catheter that  the
previous block that you put there then collect
the blood or inject the
research or treatment products that is
well the part for which Generally it is
what we are what we are
dedicated to So if you have a study
you need to collect blood every hour every
2  hours every 3 hours every 10 hours Well
there you have access to the bar or
infusions that are for the whole day or
inclusions that are good every day
depending on the study so Eh
You are going to inject the
research products or treatments in the bar
ah  It is recommended to inject a
saline solution after you have used it.
It is recommended to wash inside
the catheter and also wash the
inside of the bar and then block it again. It
is blocked with an
anticoagulant solution again like the one we
had described before.  In this way, it is
obviously already blocked.
Generally the blockage lasts two
weeks depending on the
type of maintenance. And if maintenance is done
well and if all the rules have been followed.
Well, I have
mentioned that but always use the
sterile preparation, that is better.
That said, you can't imagine how important
that is. It's also important to know
the volume of the b and the cetter. So
obviously, if you're not going to apply it, well,
neither too much deina to analyze it nor too
little catheter, well, no, it
wasn't sufficiently washed,
sufficiently blocked, so
know the volume of the bap depending
on the species depending on the bap
So it is very important so that
you do not stay praying that you do not lack it that
you do not lack it or that it is
too good like everything No what could
go
wrong Well nothing nothing is perfect enía
you know nothing  It's perfect in
biology but there are things that can
definitely go wrong, I mean I've been
working with these devices for almost 8
years and well things happen but I'll
try to avoid it because it won't happen
and try to ensure that the success of your
research is what it is.
the most important thing
is the most important goal so that everything
goes
well then
complications Well, since everything is in
the skin the skin has its own
bacteria ions can pass
yes less than with eh percutaneous zeros Yes
but according to the literature it is
estimated  that more or less can happen
between 4 and 15% infections, mostly
at the level of the so well
you are also injecting certain So
when injecting anyway there is
a puncture in the skin and
obviously the reason can
happen is  those types of situations but it
is calculated more or less between 4
and 15% it is very variable it depends on the
species it depends on the type of
vascular access port it depends on many
things but more or less that is the literature
that says that Eh it can happen  occlusion
of the
catheter absolutely or of the B with
blood residues such as fibrin
then the fibrin can act as ah
as a kind of covering the
surface at the tip of the catheter And
then uh Sometimes some bands are produced
that sometimes produce
a catheter occlusion  but well, it
can happen, but what I was telling you,
if you block it, well, they say well,
and they make all the recommendations,
generally the occlusion, well, it doesn't happen,
but it's one that can happen in other ways.  The
material is non-
absorbent, the stucture material
is not non-absorbent so that it fits well and fits
well
inside the
blood vessel. It may also happen that in
some cases there is a detachment of
the needle from the
day during
infusions, so
you have this.  doing an
investigation you have the needle stuck to the
Porto vascular access
Sorry
well giving Almost almost 35 minutes I'm going to
take
So the B needle can be dispensed
during infusions it is
possible So if they are products that
are very toxic or that are very irritating
one thing like that  What are you investigating
? It is recommended to use another type of
catheter, another type of BS to avoid that
problem. So there are some catheters that
I will show you or some BS that you can also
use in these types of situations to
avoid the detachment of the needle
from the vacuum, also causing thrombosis of the
blood vessel some products produce
irritation at the level of the vessel the vessel becomes
inflamed Then the blood vessel leaks
thrombosis like all this is a
medical equipment that is a medical product
and the BS can be uh the person can
have an adverse reaction polyurethane or
can  have an adverse reaction to the
silicone that is placed in titanium
And then obviously, any
equipment that one has implanted in the
body,
the healthy organism reacts by
reacting. I have never seen in these
years that I working with
these I Generally I have seen at
least  a lot that the animal reacted
adversely of
many that implanted but
many that
implanted well the possible causes for
which there may be
complications some may be little
training of the staff without
concentration on the details the
details for this type
of equipment it is very
important not to res  Prepare that you
need to prepare sterile properly.
So it is very important that every
time you access the bar,
the area that is going to be
treated or that is going to be prepared to
access the port is cured very well. Touch
the area. Touch the  area or materials
used with dirty gloves then
the person is not using
these gloves but is using another type
of gloves, it is true that suddenly they have
touched something
that is contaminated So they are already dirty
And then you can also introduce
bacteria into the blood vessel you can
introduce bacteria  a the al well the
blood is a culture medium well very very
good so obviously that pu a
reason
Ah another is that the ability to know
early complications of the B Like
for example inflammation seromas C
Sometimes when a makes the package in
which the B  sometimes if it doesn't close well if it does
n't close well
well a seroma can happen
and not recognizing these types
of early situations
can eventually cause a
problem when you go to access the the the the
B the size of the wrong B in
relation to the size of the animal So
for example you have a very
large catheter with a very small B a
very large animal
well many many things can be in the
important sense to recognize before
you go to buy the baps before
What type
of animal are you working with and
when does it weigh and well, everything
you need to understand that animals
are very
important common uses in  research
Here I show you some
references So for example there is
one
called System
system
that as you see it
here as you see it here This is a this is a
very good one for type of
infusions I have used it a lot
in my research and basically it
has  your catheter and the B the B the
access port the part where you
put the needle and all that is not it is
horizontal it is not it is not vertical and Enton
is not horizontal it is vertical
so it makes it easier for
a catheter to be introduced secondarily when you
leave  to
implant And then that
secondary catheter is connected to a pump where
the products that you are
researching are, whatever it is, and on the monkeys
they put a jacket like a jacket
and this secondary catheter that
secondary catheter goes in a package at the back in a
package at the back  The one in the jacket
So that way the pump
eh let's say eh does its job and
when it becomes automatic it let's say
injects what it needs to inject and
stops when it finishes its injection And
then
the investigation is done Generally
they are infusions that last an hour 2
Hours can last many hours or can
be
intermittent one hour in the morning another
in the afternoon another hour at night it
depends a lot it depends a lot on the system
to which you go the research which you
are going to
do This is another
example You can get everything on the
internet  and it will be translated if you can it
is very interesting all this type of
equipment for different types of
research
I am showing you because there are
some different studies that have been
done with this type
of this this is this is a
very complex slide
but I am trying to show
It's
Oops
Well what a pity those
who lost their cool like
we did in Colombia but for some
reason we disconnected Well I'll be back
again what I was showing you
is this slide here where,
for
example, it has a sequence of how to
They implant the ca and Cat or the
ca and Cat system that basically has the VIP
and and the other one that the other catheter but this
is how they are
implanted Show more or less
how the thing is
This is the the bp what I was showing
Here these  They are the vp and this is like
simulating that it is under the skin
with this plastic and a connector is inserted
and to that connector a line is inserted
that line goes through the
connector as seen here and it is a
secondary catheter so after  The connector is removed
and um you put a one on that
line or that catheter, well, a nylon one that's
called a lure adapter, a
lure adapter that And then in that way
the
catheter is externalized through the through the eh
B And  then a syringe is connected to the
tor l And in that way
this type of
BS is used, this is called a B for Ho these for
holes eh what they have is
underneath the silicone eh they have some little
holes And these little holes  It is like a
kind of stage with
titanium holes and is used
to reduce the lateral forces
when the pencil-type needle has been inserted.
And so it
is almost impossible for it to
slide out of the  that type of B They
slide the needle
so they are very stable so that
you can insert the needle and to remove it
is quite
difficult but it is used a lot because it makes
sure that when you are
doing an infusion or the
blood collection or a  infusion that are with, let's
say, very irritating products.
So that way, you can make sure
that it's not going to get out of there and then
cause some damage to the skin or something
like that. It's very good, very
good. Here I show you how it works.
type of through holes
Then the pencil needle is introduced and goes to the bottom of the
paper
and here we are
showing to the bottom of the bar the
pencil needle there deposits its product
or the blood is taken out or whatever and
then they have the little holes  and here it
shows how the
lateral forces of movement are reduced if the needle
moves in the eh with the animal but
Generally Generally it is very difficult
for these waters to come out of there you
have to use a lot of force and the
animal well of course  Yes, it will not be able to, it will not be able to,
even if it moves, it will not be able to
come out. It is very
stable. Well, another is the use of
Civas polyurethane catheters coated with
eparin. This is a technology that is
called Bioac Surface Sivas, which is
a process presented to apply the
heparin anticant to the surface
of plastic materials such as petane the
the active sequence of the
parin molecules serve to block the
blood coagulation cascade catheter these
catheters are widely used
especially if there are products that or that
the  animal becomes dehydrated then
the blood concentrates then the
coagulation cascade is faster well many
things can happen or they are
investigations
where it is predicted that
suddenly there will be a lot of inflammation in
the animal and then the catheter can
clot very quickly right then
what  We use these types of
catheters and they are very effective for
our special research team.
So as conclusions
before the use of baps, a
sterile preparation is essential for the success of
its long-term operation, the
training of technical personnel for
maintenance and  The use of them
is essential for the success of the
investigations in which they are
used. That is very
important and thank you all very much for
listening to me, having seen me today, sorry
for the interruption but
thank you very much everyone and if you have
questions, we will gladly have
some minutes.  More to
answer them well, if you want if you want if you
want to ask me
anything with pleasure here and I can
answer you Thank you Marcel siquera I
love that you listened to my
presentation today
and with great
pleasure especially to all the
Spanish-speaking or Spanish-speaking friends  Let's put it this way I
wanted to give them my contribution
as a
research surgeon that they would like to
ask anything with
great pleasure here are a few
more minutes so I can
ask whatever they want
and answer in my capacity
no
Well there is a
Marisol  Good
afternoon Thank you very much for your question,
where can you find the technique
described How to install this type of baps
on rats
well Generally I always say the
technique, the
rats technique, you can find it on the Internet,
that is the only thing I can tell you, it is
very
accessible and you want to go.  to the internet and
and you can get there what type there is a
company called Access access
technologies it is from here in the
United States But obviously everything can be
obtained And that company technologies
They have catheters for there are many
comp companies there but well the one that at
this moment  It comes to my
mind that they have quite a few
catheters for rats and
little mice, but that
technique is used to use rats. It
's generally in the jugular vein in the
rat or it can be in the femoral vein.
The vascular access is also
placed between  between the
uh enter the back near the
neck and it is used a lot in
rats I hope you have I hope you
are satisfied with the answer
Maris we
have 5 more minutes for those who
want to ask any question
related to vascular access ports
with  nice to meet you
ch
ot thing I wanted to tell you is that for
all those who are listening to me today
that
the academy of surgery academy of
research surgery also has
many
different categories to
certify surgeons And if you want you
can look at their page on the internet
and you can also
look for different resources there because
you can
find the Internet is always a big one
today for this type of
situations and they have a lot of
information there is a question I got
a
question what is the anest combination
that is recommended for the implementation
of the good a while ago Generally
I use ketamine and cacina I use
approximately
e eh more or less 80 mg
per kilo 80 80 mg per kilo of
ketamine and more or less I use
5 to 10 mg per kilo of
injectable cacina
which is why the collar of the gown is so
small  true it is so so so
cortico So injectable is the most
appropriate in this type
of research
he
used 80 mg of quamina and between 5 and
10 mg depending on the size of the animal
depending on the type of rat depending on
the situation I really use
that injectable ketamine and cacin 80 80
mg of quamina and more or less eh
approximately I use between 5 and 10 mg
of cacin per kilo not per kilo of
body weight I hope I have answered the
answer is appropriate let me know
if you want to know more about  what type
of
e What type of
injectables Generally in
mice the minstrel oatmeal true in
rats the minstrel vein is more appropriate
But there are reports
obviously true that it is
also possible in the rat to get femoral laena it
depends on the size of the animal again
but yes  generally it is it is the most
common thing is the jugular vein
ah we
have a minute left for them to
love each other so that they want to ask
one
more question Thank you to all those who
listened to me today and let's hope we
see each other again
in another  presentation
and I will be happy to
present this type of conference again and in
Spanish. Thank you all and have a
very happy rest of your life. Thank you very much
k
ah